[Music]
game over
game over um thoughts
i mean we saw it coming i guess for a
while i think kim
who's who's next is the only thing i've
been wondering is i think it's drake
right it's got to be drake there's only
one way to go
only one way to go and it's it's such
the kardashian move and it's such the
drake move
because drake we talked about dancing on
graves drake or dance on your [ __ ]
drake is a killer yeah dude oh that's a
great i didn't even put that together
like his beat with kanye
oh he he wants it yeah all the friends
with the kardashians oh yeah
that's the neighbors yeah they were all
homies yeah and he's been alluding to it
for a while but now that it's done so
it's the perfect move for both of them
he already alluded that he [ __ ] it
yeah but now he's smashed
now there's no there don't there's no
need to elude anymore now you're single
now i can just openly be with you the
jlo style post or whatever he did even
if it's not real remember that post he
had with jlo where it looked like they
had been [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah he could
do the exact same thing with him not
that one i forgot
they're all snuggled up i think they're
wearing bathrobes or some [ __ ] like that
something it was like a couple years ago
he came out to her residency in vegas
and they would have known a picture like
that you're both in robes
they know what they're doing they're
like yo let's shake up the internet for
a day you could do the same [ __ ] and
who's more willing to do that than kim
and she always moves up yeah this is i
don't know about fame or any of that
[ __ ] but drake is a mega mega star
whose scene is sane and
cool and all of that [ __ ] and like
that's that's the only
only chess move left and it's checkmate
really is it weird that like
with there's much to criticize about the
kardashians don't get me wrong
okay but with
kim specifically and kanye
i think she's the victim
without a doubt like like we could we
could talk about
all the things that the kardashians do
that are potentially disgusting
but in this specific relationship like
remove kim as the person who
came to fame through a sex tape and her
mother essentially pimping that out and
like
them you know projecting this specific
lifestyle and potentially using and
cooking up this drama and
destroying maybe people's lives on the
way and profiting off of that right
let's remove them from the kardashians
specifically kim kardashian with kanye
west yeah
if kanye is crazy which i think we
believe is true
mentally ill mentally ill the
politically correct podcast
which is called [ __ ] ted cruz a
[ __ ] for 30 minutes
but if if kanye's mentally ill i
know a motherfucker's men's leader yeah
that [ __ ] is exhausting bruh
yeah you have a different level of
empathy for that hey
this guy is driving tanks in wyoming you
got to just put up with him wanted to go
drive tanks in wyoming
support him along the way you bailed his
broke ass out
think about this you married this guy
who's telling you he's a genius all the
time and he just keeps losing more and
more millions
and you're looking at him like ain't
looking too genius right about now
right finally you get him cooked up with
some power players right
the scooters of the world yeah to get
the easy thing going he becomes a
billionaire sure
i don't know if he gets that connect and
that gets that put together without kim
i don't know if they it's interesting i
don't know
he had enough to bring all of those
people to him before
the kardashians came around that's riled
up that was
disgusting that [ __ ] grossed me out
i felt like a kardashian i was looking
like kendall
where did you get that outfit you did it
and i might have i got it at bash what
was their store
back in the day dash so
i think kim is definitely the victim i'm
surprised they lasted that long
yeah and we're losing victim we're using
victim loosely here
we're not dealing with a horrible person
to be with she's the hero
she she's dealing with a crazy human
being yeah all these terms are relative
yeah yeah i guess that's what i'm saying
i don't want to like exactly like they
are women
for me to feel bad for any kardashian
because i don't look at them as human
beings
but if i put on the glasses of this is
an actual human being with a soul
i see how she's a victim this is the
only way i look at it if she didn't have
kids
i'd be like you're an idiot like why are
you staying with this guy why should
keep having kids though
she loves having kids man yeah yeah yeah
she's a woman that's what they do
cute kids too yeah and they make some
cute kids so so
here's the thing like you love
potentially you love this guy yeah she
definitely who's crazy
right you stay with him you rock with
him he's broke
[ __ ] your whole brand up you could
clip that off
it's not like she hasn't clipped
[ __ ] before she he's doing
crazy [ __ ] that makes your brand
look stupid she make the the mega [ __ ]
made her look crazy she's trying to get
good will in the black community for
[ __ ] decades
what do i have to do i'm getting black
guys out of jail and then all of a
sudden
my black husband who's the father of my
half black kids
is walking around a [ __ ] mega head
what the [ __ ] are you doing
i push back on that whoa what is there
to push back on
because every bit of controversy does
help their brand
i mean she started that magazine she
started her
i'm telling you in yes they haven't
found a way to monetize
interest i agree with what you're what
what you're saying right here akash like
correct me if i'm wrong but what you're
saying is if they have eyeballs they
make money it doesn't matter if they're
good or bad i think they are keenly
aware of that and do
a lot of things to get 100 i also do
think
she's been doing a lot to curry favor
within the black community specifically
of late getting the criminal justice
reform
rebranding herself that's why i feel
worse for her because she's
actually you we can see the work that
she's done legally blonde [ __ ] sit your
ass down but i mean like
she's not so focused on just like
breaking the internet and [ __ ] like that
like she's just a mom
who loves her kids and who's been trying
to make her marriage work she really
hasn't been doing all the [ __ ]
[ __ ] she used to do in the past
so that's the only reason why i feel
sorry for her because she's actually
tried to
oh i don't feel sorry no i feel sorry
for it i'll feel sorry i feel sorry for
her so
she that's not what she signed up for
i'm also fine i'll leave exactly
i would be totally okay with that if
they were there but they did live apart
for a good part of the last three years
he was living in wyoming she's living in
l.a like they weren't even living
together so right that's fire
that's fire this guy's tired
oh my god i'm driving a [ __ ] tank
dolo
just living the life so point is
i don't know i don't know like i'm
looking at this situation and i actually
i'm like yo she was
a ride or die ass chick word
for this [ __ ] crazy egomaniac
word who did nothing positive
for if she's if the premise is all i do
is care about the brand and all i want
to do is do more [ __ ] for the brand
did nothing positive for the brand nah
definitely helped the brand in the
beginning
kanye linking up with kim legitimized
her from just
being like some athletes [ __ ]
persona that's like on instagram and
[ __ ] like that like she
became high fashion after kanye so it
boosted her brand but then she
capitalized off that and
created an empire with it so kanye
definitely helped her
because we were looking i needed a lot
of people we were looking at her like
before
who were her guys reggie bush was a
college star
fine as a pro nothing crazy miles austin
couple good years
and then she married chris humphrey yeah
that come on like my man is like selling
houses or something you know what's
crazy is like she could have really
liked them you know
like she could have liked that like this
is this this is how [ __ ] up we are
right is we're like yo you didn't just
gold dig
and go after the most successful famous
person you idiot
when when if
we should be looking at her going oh
[ __ ] she actually found some guys that
weren't the best but maybe they had cool
personality and they connected and asked
why she [ __ ] with them and we're
criticizing her for that
we're criticizing her for what we wish
every girl would do i'm actually not
like a dude's personality
i'm not with chris humphries because of
how good he is i'm not criticizing her
i'm making fun of them you got you had
bum dudes that's fine you had bum dudes
great you loved him i don't that's like
how do you make fun of them they got the
[ __ ] kim kardashian's getting six
rebounds a game yeah i'm just making fun
of their skill level that's it as a
pleasant athlete
but for the brand you're not elevated
you're not elevated marrying chris
humphrey
you're not like oh [ __ ] chris kim
kardashian got chris you're making my
point
exactly no so i can agree with your
point i'm just saying even then
to agree with alex's point then when you
get with kanye now
now you're a different person yeah
you're you're from i'm talking about
kim now but kim when she was with chris
humphries we
like some people wouldn't wanted to [ __ ]
her she had a sex tape out like that's
how
that was her claim to fame who would
want to wipe that a lot of people would
have a mad stink on her like no
there you go now that's a great argument
kanye removed the sex tape stank
i'll give you that 100 percent empire
blew up after that
he re so there was still this stench of
the sex tape even though this next day
became like a popular way to become
famous you know we saw a lot of girls do
it there was still a stench
of it right and they had their tv show
and there was this home family and you
got to you know understand them and meet
them and they seemed normal and they
said bible
after to promise something like that she
didn't say that before she was taking
the dangle
but uh but in all seriousness she goes
and gets with kanye and all of a sudden
he removes that stench
and that is invaluable and i wonder if
that was
by design on her behalf and i wonder if
his ego was also going a little part of
him was like you know how like a chef
goes
yeah i could turn this parson up into a
steak yeah i could sell that [ __ ] for
for a hundred dollars because i'm so
nice of being a chef these [ __ ]
will eat a parsnip steak
and i wonder if he was like i could turn
this
[ __ ]
i could turn this sex tape [ __ ] who
[ __ ]
you know wide receivers
that barely in the league still into the
most desired woman on the planet
and removed the stench of that sex tape
have her talk on the president's
i wonder if that was his ego tapping it
maybe that's so because he claimed to do
that for amber
and he would remember when him and uh
kim first got together
he would dress kim son she was obsessed
with her
yeah for a while son kanye he made her
that's how i knew he was mentally ill
go on i mean listen you in love with
this
kim kardashian you obsessed with kim
kardashian
writing diss songs for chris humphrey
before that was amber
now this song's just chris humphries is
hilarious like that this one's with
chris humphreys
that's his lunatic behavior stats you
don't need to do a whole song
you're bullying me now bro they put me
on tv for half a season and she divorced
me for ratings
they made him look like an [ __ ] yo
but kanye takes bodies off of your belt
yeah like everybody if you're a girl
and you got a hundred bodies right
you got 100 dicks is what i'm basically
trying to say
kanye knocks off ninety percent of your
dicks
if the [ __ ] march was a person it would
be kanye west here's the thing he ends
up well that's a hilarious observation
[ __ ] marsh leans into being a [ __ ]
kanye removes your [ __ ] i don't know if
he's still got the clout to do it
but at one point in time he had enough
clout to make people
forget that you were a stripper forget
that you might have done some sex for
money who knows
and forget that you had a [ __ ] sex
tape out
that's clout when your dick cleanses a
[ __ ]
you dick cleanses [ __ ] bro you're
dipping them in holy water
jesus walks real tall baptizing [ __ ]
baptizing these hoes man kanye
is the goat hallelujah for whole usually
you put your dick in a girl and there's
one more body
he puts his dick in girls pulls out
bodies pulls out bodies
holy [ __ ] mortal kombat scorpion dick
you